pandemic life is pretty static a lot of
us have never had so much time at home
much of it's spent sitting waiting some
gyms and pools and spinning studios are
beginning to open with big modifications
of course we asked Liam vu to delve into
the challenges and opportunities facing
the fitness industry with so many
Canadians anxious to resume their
workouts three months ago the fitness
industry was booming generating one
hundred and twenty seven point four
billion dollars globally and then the
new reality Cobin 19 forced gyms around
the world to close pushing the health
and wellness industry into a vast
unknown while Canadians scrambled to
find ways to stay fit under lockdown
[Music]
lissa Balestra is a sixty-year-old
financial consultant who is pushing back
against the pandemic she goes on daily
walks and runs and every other day
dedicates two hours to strength training
I worked out all my life so at different
stages of my life I had different
reasons why to work out when I was
younger was more of a competitive after
children it was more to stay in shape
and keep up with the kids
4050 the aches and pains were coming she
has no choice but to keep moving
she's living with arthritis a herniated
disc and spinal stenosis which can
trigger excruciating pain in her neck I
find that if I don't exercise the pain
will start again when you're in pain and
constant pain I think it's such a mental
toll on you
and it can put you into into depression
high anxiety a recent poll found thirty
percent of Canadians were feeling
anxiety about the pandemic triggering
other issues with 29 percent saying
they're overeating the same number also
reporting a lack of exercise
there's long-standing research to show
that there's a relationship between
physical activity and mental health
being more active improves mood symptoms
of depression symptoms of anxiety we
can't really fight the research anymore
on that and it's not just everyday
Canadians struggling to find motivation
celebrities they're just like us
actor Bill Murray partnered up with his
local gym to promote their at home
workouts a service many studios started
to offer Kali reikus is a former TV
producer who took a leap of faith two
years ago and opened a 7,000 square foot
fitness facility in Toronto before the
lockdown the studio offered 16 classes
serving several hundred members on a
daily basis the pandemic required
pivoting renting out weights and leading
workouts online it was about finding
connection in a physically distant world
of course it's different to teach people
online than it is teach them in person
however I think we need to take a minute
to reflect on how privileged and lucky
we are to be in a time where
we can still connect with people face to
face and of course another really
amazing benefit of the virtual world
that we've kind of discovered is that we
can serve more people from you know more
places farther away and while there's no
shortage of motivation online finding
fitness gear continues to be an exercise
in patience and endurance last March in
the US retail sales for training
equipment surged by 130 percent compared
to last year
that demand simply exceeding the supply
the last month or two the supplies have
been very low because our suppliers have
run out of inventory they're very close
to catching up and a lot of our
shipments are coming in now so we'll be
able to fulfill the hundreds of orders
that we've been getting turns out the
supply chain for fitness equipment
especially free weights had the same
vulnerabilities as personal protective
equipment most of it made overseas
making them hard to get during a
worldwide pandemic but necessity is the
mother of invention and so many
Canadians have adapted finding unique
ways and objects to work out with select
gyms reopens across Canada in early June
like Club 16 in BC with new protocols
and reduced capacity meanwhile gyms in
Toronto remain closed but an upcoming
yoga events is still pushing ahead
allowing participants to step out of
their at-home bubble into another one
but the fitness industry may never be
the same we know one of the main
barriers to people exercising is the
fear of going into a gym in the first
place you know what where do you look
where do you go where that what kind of
equipment do you use even those who
didn't experience that anxiety going
into a gym may now experience it for
some individuals will be very
anxiety-provoking
addressing physical and mental health is
something that gyms will have to tackle
once doors reopen in some cases doors
that never opened in the first place
tried space yoga was set to open in the
spring but kovin 19 put a pause on the
poses owner Jordanna Ricketts
acknowledges the lockdown could bankrupt
her but says Canadians will eventually
mean more than just a physical reset
they'll need a mental one after months
of isolation when you appeal to their
sites the sounds with the music and the
smells with the incense
the sage that we have burning at all
times here all of those factors combined
is really what's gonna draw people here
and really get them to feel that feeling
of relaxation leasable essary finds that
calm by working out it's not just a
physical necessity it's also a way for
her to stay connected to her late father
these are a special way they're my dad's
weights so they've been in my basement
as a child you know he had a lot of
physical challenges in his later years
right but you know what he was out there
walking she is unsure if she will ever
step back into a gym she's just happy to
continue being active blazing her own
trail
[Music]